MICHALE FEE: So who
remembers what that's called?
A spectrograph.
Good.
And it's a spectrogram of me.
Good morning, class.
OK.
So it's a spectrogram of speech.
And so we are going
to continue today
on the topic of understanding--
developing methods
for understanding
how to characterize
and understand
temporally structured signals.
So that is the
microphone recording
of my voice saying
"good morning, class."
And then this is a spectrogram
of that signal where
at each moment in
time, you can actually
extract the spectral
structure of that signal.
And you can see that the
information in speech signals
is actually carried in parts of
the signal in the way the power
in the signal at different
frequencies changes over time.
And your ears detect
these changes in frequency
and translate that
into information
about what I'm saying.
And so we're going to
today start on a-- well,
we sort of started last
time, but we're really
going to get going on this
in the next three lectures.
We're going to develop
a powerful set of tools
for characterizing
and understanding
the temporal
structure of signals.
So this is the game plan
for the next three lectures.
Today we're going to
cover Fourier series--
complex Fourier series.
We're going to extend that
to the idea of the Fourier
transform.
And then so the
Fourier transform
is sort of a very general
mathematical approach
to understanding the temporal
structure of signals.
That's more of a--
you think of that
more in terms of doing
analytical calculations or sort
of conceptual understanding
of what Fourier
decomposition is.
But then there's a
very concrete algorithm
for characterizing spectral
structure of signals called
the fast Fourier transform.
And that's one class of methods
where you sample signals
discretely in time and
get back discrete power
at discrete frequencies.
So that's called a
discrete Fourier transform.
And most often that's
used to compute
the power spectrum of signals.
And so that's what we're
going to cover today.
And then in the
next lecture, we're
going to cover a number
of topics leading up
to spectral estimation.
We're going to start with the
convolution theorem, which
is a really powerful
way of understanding
the relationship
between convolution
in the time domain and
multiplication of things
in the frequency domain.
And the convolution
theorem is really powerful,
allowing you to kind of
think about, intuitively
understand the spectral
structure of different kinds
of signals that you can build
by convolving different sort
of basic elements.
So if you understand the Fourier
decomposition of a square pulse
and a train of
pulses or a Gaussian,
you can basically just by
kind of thinking about it
figure out the
spectral structure
of a lot of different signals
by just combining those things
sort of like LEGO blocks.
It's super cool.
We're going to talk about
noise and filtering.
the Shannon-Nyquist sampling
theorem, which tells
you how fast you
have to sample a signal in order
to perfectly reconstruct it.
It turns out it's
really amazing.
If you have a
signal in time, you
can sample that signal
at regular intervals
and perfectly
reconstruct the signal
if that signal doesn't have
frequency components that
are too high.
And so that's captured in
this Shannon-Nyquist sampling
theorem.
That turns out to actually
be a topic of current debate.
There was a paper
published recently
by somebody claiming to be
able to get around the sampling
theorem and record neural
signals without having
to guarantee the
conditions under which
the Shannon-Nyquist
sampling theorem claims.
And Markus Meister wrote
a scathing rebuttal
to that basically claiming
that they're full of baloney.
And so those folks who
wrote that paper maybe
should have taken this class.
So anyway, you don't want
to be on the wrong end
of Markus Meister's blog post.
So pay attention.
So then we're going to get
into spectral estimation.
Then in the last
lecture, we're going
to talk about spectrograms.
We're going to talk about
how to compute spectrograms
and understand really
how to take the data
and break it into
samples called windowing,
how to multiply those samples
by what's called a taper
to avoid contaminating
the signal with lots
of noise that's unnecessary.
We're going to understand the
idea of time bandwidth product.
How do you choose the
width of that window
to emphasize different
parts of the data?
And then we're going to end
with some advanced filtering
methods that are commonly used
to control different frequency
components of
signals in your data.
So a bunch of really
powerful things.
Here's what we're going
to talk about today.
We're going to continue
with this Fourier series.
We started with symmetric
functions last time.
We're going to finish
that and then talk
about asymmetric functions.
We're going to extend that
to complex Fourier series,
introduce the Fourier transform
and the discrete Fourier
transform and this algorithm
and the fast Fourier transform,
and then I'm going to show you
how to compute power spectrum.
So just to make it
clear, all of this stuff
is basically going
to be to teach you
how to use one line of MATLAB.
One function, FFT.
Now, the problem is it's
really easy to do this wrong.
It's really easy
to use this but not
understand what you're doing and
come up with the wrong answer.
So all of these things that
we're going to talk about today
are just the kind
of basics that you
need to understand in order to
use this very powerful function
in MATLAB.
All right.
So let's get started.
So last time, we introduced
the idea of a Fourier series.
We talked about
the idea that you
can approximate any
periodic function.
So here I'm just taking a
square wave that alternates
between positive and negative.
It's periodic with
a period capital T.
So it's a function of time.
It's a even function or
a symmetric function,
because you can see that
it's basically mirror
symmetry around the y-axis.
It's even because
even polynomials also
have that property
of being symmetric.
We can approximate
this periodic function
T as a sum of sine waves or
cosine waves, in this case.
We can approximate that as a
cosine wave of the same period
and the same amplitude.
So we can approximate as a
coefficient times cosine 2 pi
f0 t where f0 is just
1 over the period.
So if the period is one
second, then the frequency
is 1 hertz, 1 over 1 second.
We often use this
different representation
of frequency, which is
usually called omega,
which is angular frequency.
And it's just 2 pi times
this oscillation frequency.
And it has units of
radians per second.
So we talked about
the fact that you
can approximate this periodic
function as a sum of cosines.
We talked about the
idea that you only
need to consider cosines that
are integer multiples of omega
0, because those are the
only cosine functions,
those are the only
functions, that also are
periodic at frequency omega 0.
So a function cosine
3 omega 0 t is also
periodic at frequency omega 0.
Does that make sense?
So now we can approximate
any periodic function.
In this case, any even
or symmetric periodic
function as a sum of cosines
of frequencies that are
integer multiples of omega 0.
And each one of
those cosines will
have a different coefficient.
So here's an example where I'm
approximating this square wave
here as a sum of cosines of
these different frequencies.
And it turns out
for a square wave,
you only need the odd
multiples of omega 0.
So here's what
this approximation
looks like for the case where
you only have a single cosine
function.
You can add another
cosine of 3 omega 0 t
and you can see that that
function starts getting
a little bit more square.
You can add a
cosine 5 omega 0 t.
And as you keep
adding those things,
again, with the correct
coefficients in front of these,
you can see that the
function more and more
closely approximates the square
wave that we're trying to--
yes, Habiba
AUDIENCE: Why do we only
need the odd multiples?
MICHALE FEE: It
just, in general, you
need all the multiples.
But for this
particular function,
you only need the odd ones.
Here's another example.
So in this case, we are summing
together cosine functions
to approximate a
train of pulses.
So the signal we're
trying to approximate here
just has a pulse every one
unit of time, one period.
And you can see that
to approximate this,
we can basically just
sum up all the cosines
of all frequencies n omega 0.
And you can see that at time
0, all of those functions
are positive.
And so all of those positive
contributions to that sum
all add up.
And as you add them
up, you get a big peak.
That's called
constructive interference.
So all those peaks add up.
And you also get those peaks
all adding up one period away.
One period of cosine omega 0.
You can see they add up again.
So you can see this is
a periodic function.
In this time window
between those peaks,
you can see that you have
positive peaks of some
of those cosines, negative
peaks, positive, negative.
They just sort of all add up.
They interfere with
each other destructively
to give you a 0 in the
intervals between the peaks.
Does that make sense?
And so basically, by
choosing the amplitude
of these different
cosine functions,
you can basically build any
arbitrary periodic function
down here.
Does that makes sense?
All right.
There's one more
element that we need
to add here for our Fourier
series for even functions.
Anybody have any
idea what that is?
Notice here I've shifted this
function up a little bit.
So it's not centered at 0.
A constant term.
What's called a DC term.
We basically take the
average of that function.
We add it here.
That's called a DC term.
a 0 over 2 is
essentially the average
of the function we're
trying to approximate.
All right.
Good.
We can now write that as a sum.
y even of t equals
a0 over 2 plus a sum
over all these different
n's of a sub n,
which is a coefficient,
times cosine n omega 0 t.
Omega 0 is 1 over--
is 2 pi over this time
interval here, the periodicity.
All right.
Good.
How do we find
those coefficients?
So I just told you that the
first coefficient, the a 0
over 2, is just the
average of our function t
over one time window from minus
t over 2 to plus t over 2.
It's just the integral
of that function
over one period divided by t.
And that gives you the
average, which is a 0 over 2.
All right, any
questions about that?
It's pretty straightforward.
What about this next
coefficient, a1?
So the a1 coefficient is just
the overlap of our function
y of t with this cosine.
We're just multiplying y0
times cosine of omega 0 t
integrating over time and
then multiplying by 2 over t.
So that's the answer.
And I'm going to
explain why that is.
That is just a correlation.
It's just like asking how much--
let's say we had a neuron with a
receptive field of cosine omega
0 t.
We're asking how well
does our signal overlap
with that receptive field.
Does that make sense?
We're just
correlating our signal
with some basis function,
with some receptive field.
And we're asking how
much overlap is there.
The a2 coefficient is just
the overlap of the function
y with cosine 2 omega 0 t.
And the a sub n
coefficient is just
the overlap with
cosine n omega 0 t.
Just like that.
And you can see that this
average that we took up here
just is the
generalization of this
to the overlap of our function
to cosine 0 omega 0 t.
Cosine 0 omega 0 t is just 1.
And so this coefficient a0
just looks the same as this.
It's just that in this
case, it turns out
to be the average
of the function.
Any questions about that?
So that is, in general, how you
calculate those coefficients.
So you would literally
just take your function,
multiply it by a cosine of
some frequency, integrate it,
and that's the answer.
Let's just take a look at what
some of these coefficients
are for some really
simple functions.
So there I've rewritten what
each of those coefficients
is as an integral.
And now let's consider
the following function.
So let's say our function is 1.
It's just a constant at 1.
So you can see that this
integral from minus t over 2
to t over 2, that integral is
just t multiplied by 2 over t
gives that
coefficient as just 2.
If our function is
cosine omega 0 t,
you can see that if you put a
cosine in here, that averages
to 0.
If you put a cosine in here,
you get cosine squared.
The integral of cosine
squared is just half
of basically the full range.
So that's just t over 2.
When you multiply by
2 over t, you get 1.
And the coefficient a2 for
a function cosine omega t
is 0, because the integral
of cosine omega 0 t times
cosine 2 omega 0 t is 0.
All right.
If we have a function
cosine 2 omega 0 t,
then these coefficients are
0, and that coefficient is 1.
You can see that you have
this interesting thing here.
If your function is
cosine omega 0 t,
then the only coefficient
that's non-zero
is the one that you're
overlapping with cosine omega 0
t.
It's only this first
coefficient that's non-zero.
If your function has a
frequency 2 omega 0 t,
then the only coefficient
that's non-zero is the a2.
So what that means is
that if the function has
maximal overlap, if it overlaps
one of those cosines, then
it has 0 overlap
with all the others.
And we can say that set
of cosine functions,
cosine omega 0 t,
cosine 2 omega 0 t,
forms what's called an
orthogonal basis set.
We're going to spend a lot of
time talking about basis set
later, but I'm just going
to throw this word out
to you so that
you've heard it when
I come back to the idea
of basis sets later.
You're going to see
this connection.
So the basic idea is
that what we're doing
is we're taking our
signal, which is a vector.
It's a set of points in time.
We can think of that as a vector
in a high dimensional space.
And we're simply expressing it
in a new basis set of cosines
of different frequencies.
So each of those functions,
cosine n omega t,
is like a vector in a basis set.
Our signal like a vector.
And what we're doing is when
we're doing these projections,
we're simply computing
the projection
of that vector, our signal,
onto these different basis
functions, these
different basis vectors.
So we're just finding
the coefficient
so that we can
express our signal
as a sum of a coefficient
times a basis vector
plus another coefficient times
another basis vector and so on.
So for example, in the
simple standard basis
where this vector is 0 1
and that vector is 1 0,
you can write down
an arbitrary vector
as a coefficient times this plus
another coefficient times that.
That make sense?
And how do we find
those coefficients?
We just take our
vector and dot it
onto each one of these
basis vectors, x2.
Does that make sense?
You don't need to know
this for this section,
but we're going to
come back to this.
I would like you to
eventually kind of combine
these views of taking signals
and looking at projections
of those into new basis sets.
And as you know, how
you see things depends
on how you're looking at
them, the direction that you
look at them.
That's what we're doing.
When we take a signal and we
project it onto a function,
we're taking a particular
view of that function.
So as you know, the view
you have on something
has a big impact
on what you see.
Right?
So that's all we're doing
is we're taking functions
and finding the
projection on which we
can see something interesting.
That's it.
That's all spectral analysis is.
And the particular
views we're looking at
are projections onto
different periodic functions.
Cosines of different
frequencies.
All right?
And what you find is that
for periodic signals,
there are certain views where
something magically pops out
and you see what's there that
you can't see when you just
look at the time domain.
All right.
So we looked at even functions
or symmetric functions.
Now let's take a
look at odd functions
are antisymmetric functions.
These are called odd because
the odd polynomials like x cubed
looks like this.
If it's negative
on one side, it's
positive on the other side.
Same here.
If it's negative here,
then it's positive there.
So we can now write down Fourier
series for odd or antisymmetric
functions.
What do you think
we're going to use?
Instead of cosines, we're going
to use sines, because sines
are symmetric around--
antisymmetric around the origin.
And we're still going to
consider functions that
are periodic with period t.
We can take any
antisymmetric function
and approximate it as a sum
of sine waves of frequency 2
pi over t or, again, omega 0.
And integer multiples
of that omega 0.
All right.
So again, our odd functions
can be approximated
as a sum of components,
contributions
of different frequencies
with a coefficient times
sine of omega 0 t plus
another coefficient times
sine of 2 omega 0 t and so on.
And we can write that as a
sum that looks like this.
So a sum over n from 1 to
infinity of coefficient b
sub n times sine of n omega 0 t.
And why is there
no DC term here?
Good.
Because an antisymmetric
function can't have a DC
offset.
So for arbitrary functions, you
can write down any arbitrary
periodic function as the
sum of a symmetric part
and an antisymmetric part.
So we can write
down an arbitrary
function as a sum
of these cosines
plus a sum of sine waves.
So that's Fourier series.
Any questions about that?
So this is kind of messy.
And it turns out that there's a
much simpler way of writing out
functions as sums of
periodic functions.
So rather than using
cosines and sines,
we're going to use
complex exponentials.
And that is what complex
Fourier series does.
All right, so let's do that.
So you probably recall
that you can write down
a complex exponential e to the
i omega t as a cosine omega
t plus i sine omega t.
So e to the i omega t
is just a generalization
of sines and cosines.
So the way to
think about this is
e to the i omega t
is a complex number.
If we plot it in a
complex plane where
we look at the real
part along this axis,
the imaginary part along
that axis, e to the i omega
t just lives on this circle.
No matter what omega t is,
e to the i omega t just
sits on this circle in the
complex plane, the unit
circle in the complex plane.
e to the i omega t is
a function of time.
It simply has a real part
that looks like cosine.
So the real part of this as you
increase t or the phase omega t
is the real part just oscillates
sinusoidally back and forth
like this as a cosine.
The imaginary part just
oscillates back and forth
as a sine.
And when you put them
together, something
that goes back and forth
this way as a cosine
and up and down that way as a
sine just traces out a circle.
So e to the i omega traces out
a circle in this direction,
and as time increases, it
just goes around and around
like this.
E to the minus i omega t
just goes the other way.
That make sense?
Got the real part that's going
like this, the imaginary part
that's going like this.
And you put those
together and they just
go around in a circle.
So you can see it's a
way of combining cosine
and sine together
in one function.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to rewrite our Fourier
series as instead of sines
and cosines, we're
going to stick
in e to the-- we're going
to replace the sines
and cosines with e to the i
omega t and e to the minus i
omega t.
So we're just going to solve
these two functions for cosine
and sine, and we're going
to take this and plug it
into our Fourier series
and see what we get.
So let's do that.
And remember, 1 over
i is just minus i.
So here's our Fourier
series with our sum
of cosines, our sum of sines.
We're just going to
replace those things
with the e to the i omega
t plus e to the minus
i omega t and so on.
So there we go.
Just replacing that.
There's a 1/2 there.
And now we're just going
to do some algebra.
And we're going to collect
either the i omega t's and e to
the minus i omega t's together.
And this is what it looks like.
So you can see that
what we're doing
is collecting this
into a bunch of terms
that have e to the
positive in omega
t here and e to the
minus in omega 0 t there.
And now we have still
a sum of three things.
So it doesn't really look like
we've really gotten anywhere.
But notice something.
If we just put the
minus sign into the n,
then we can combine
these two into one sum.
And this, if n is 0, what
is e to the in omega t?
It's just 1.
So we can also write this as
something e to the in omega t
as long as n is 0.
So that's what we do.
Oh, and by the way,
these coefficients here
we can just rewrite as sums of
those coefficients up there.
Don't worry.
This all looks
really complicated.
By the end, it's just boiled
down to one simple thing.
That's why we're doing this.
We're simplifying things.
So when you do this,
when you rewrite this,
this looks like a
sum over n equals 0.
This is a sum over positive
n, n equals 1 to infinity.
This is a sum over negative
n, minus 1 to minus infinity.
And all those
combine into one sum.
So now we can write
down any function y of t
as a sum over n
equals minus infinity
to infinity of a coefficient a
sub n times e to the in omega.
So we went from having this
complicated thing, this sum
over our constant terms,
sines, and cosines,
and we boiled it
down to a single sum.
That's why these complex
exponentials are useful.
Because we don't
have to carry around
a bunch of different functions,
different basis functions
to describe an
arbitrary signal y.
But remember, this is
just a mathematical trick
to hide sines and cosines.
A very powerful trick,
but that's all it's doing.
It's hiding sines and cosines.
All right.
So we've replaced our sums
over coastlines and signs
with a sum of
complex exponentials.
All right.
Remember what we're doing here.
We're finding a new way
of writing down functions.
So what's cool
about this, what's
really interesting about this,
is that for some functions--
so what we're doing is we
have an arbitrary function y.
And we're writing a down with
just some numbers a sub n.
And what's cool about this
is that for some functions y,
you can describe that
function with just a few
of these coefficients a.
Does that make sense?
So let me just
show you an example
of some functions
that look really,
really simple when
you rewrite them
using these coefficients a.
So here's an example.
So here's a function of
n that has three numbers.
a sub minus 1, n equals
minus 1 is 1/2, a sub 0 is 0,
and a sub 1 is 1/2.
And all the rest of them are 0.
So really, we only have two
non-zero entries in this sum.
So what function is that?
It's just a cosine.
So we have-- let's
write this out.
Y equals a sum over
all of these things.
1/2 e to the minus--
the first n is minus 1. e to
the minus i omega 0 t plus 1/2 e
to the plus i omega 0 t.
We're just writing out that sum.
And that is just--
sorry, I didn't tell you
what that equation was.
That's Euler's equation.
That's just cosine
minus i sine omega t.
That is just cosine
plus i sine omega t.
The sines cancel.
And you're left with
cosine omega 0 t.
So here's this function of
time that goes on infinitely.
If you wanted to write down all
the values of cosine omega 0 t,
you'd have to write down
an awful lot of numbers.
And here we can write down that
same function with two numbers.
So this is a very compact
view of that function of time.
Here's another function.
What function do
you think that is?
What would be the time
domain equivalent of this set
of Fourier coefficients?
Good.
So we're going to
do the same thing.
Just write it out.
All these sums are 0.
All these components are
0 except for two of them.
n equals minus 2
and n equals plus 2.
You just put those
in there as 1/2
e to the minus 2 omega 0 t plus
1/2 e to the plus 2 omega 0 t.
And that is just if you write
that out, those sines cancel,
and you have cosine 2 omega 0 t.
Pretty simple, right?
How about this one?
This is the-- remember, the
a's are complex numbers.
The ones we were looking at
here had two real numbers.
Here's an example where
the a's are imaginary.
One is i over 2.
One is minus i over 2.
That's what the complex
Fourier representation
looks like of this function.
We can just plug it in here.
You solve that, you can
see that in this case,
the cosines cancel,
because this is i over 2
cosine 2 omega t minus i
over 2 cosine 2 omega t.
Those cancel and you're
left with sine 2 omega 0 t.
So that is what Fourier
representation of sine 2 omega
t looks like.
So the functions that
have higher frequencies
will have non-zero elements
that are further out in n.
Any questions about that?
So again, this set of
functions e to the in omega 0 t
form an orthogonal, orthonormal
basis set over that [INAUDIBLE]
over that interval.
The a0 coefficient is
just the projection
of our function onto e to the 0.
n equals 0.
And that's just the average.
The a1 coefficient is just
the projection of our function
e to the minus i omega 0 t.
And in general, the
m-th coefficient
is just the projection
of our function onto e
to the minus im omega 0 t.
And we can take
those coefficients,
plug them into this sum,
and reconstruct an arbitrary
periodic function, this y of t.
So we have a way of
taking a function
and getting these complex
Fourier coefficients.
And we have a way of
taking those coefficients
and reconstructing our function.
This is just a bunch of
different views function y.
And from all of those
different views,
we can reconstruct our function.
That's all it is.
So in general, when we
do Fourier decomposition
in a computer in
MATLAB on real signals
that you've sampled
in time, it's
always done in this kind
of discrete representation.
You've got, in this case,
discrete frequencies.
When you sample
signals, you've got
functions that are discrete in
time, and this becomes a sum.
But before we go to
the discrete case,
I just want to
show you what this
looks like when we go to the
case of arbitrary functions.
Remember, this thing
was about representing
periodic functions.
You can only represent
periodic functions
using these Fourier series.
But before we go on to the
Fourier transform algorithm
and discrete Fourier
transforms, I just
want to show you what this looks
like for the case of arbitrary
functions.
And I'm just
showing this to you.
I don't expect you to be able
to reproduce any of this.
But you should see what it
looks like, for those of you who
haven't seen it already.
So what we're going to
do is go from the case
of periodic functions to
non-periodic functions.
And the simplest way
to think about that
is a periodic function
does something here,
and then it just does
the same thing here,
the same thing here.
So how do we go from this
to an arbitrary function?
Well, we're just going to let
the period go to infinity.
Does that make sense?
That's actually pretty easy.
We're going to let t
go to infinity, which
means the frequencies, which
are 2 pi omega 0 or 2 pi over t,
that's going to go to 0.
So our steps.
Remember when we had this
discrete Fourier transform
here, we had these steps in
frequency as a function of n.
Those steps are just going to
get infinitely close together,
the different frequency bins.
So that's what we're
going to do now.
You're just going to let
those frequency steps go to 0.
And now frequency,
in discrete case,
the frequency is just that
number, that n times omega 0.
m times omega 0.
Well, omega 0 is going to 0, but
the m's are getting really big.
So we can just change--
we're just going
to call that omega.
The omega 0's are
going to 0, so the m's
are getting infinitely big.
So we can't really
use m anymore or n
to label our frequency steps.
So we're just
going to use omega.
We used to call
our coefficients,
our Fourier coefficients, we
used to label them with m.
We can't use m anymore, because
m is getting infinitely big.
So we use this new label omega.
So a sub m becomes a new
variable, our Fourier
transform, labeled by
the frequency omega.
And we're just going
to basically just make
those replacements in here.
So the coefficients become
a function of frequency.
That's just an integral.
Remember, t is going
to infinity now.
So this has to go
from minus infinity
to infinity of our function
y times our basis function.
And instead of e to
the im omega 0 t,
we just replace m
omega 0 with omega.
So e to the minus i omega t.
And that is the
Fourier transform.
And we're just going to do
the same replacement here,
but instead of summing over
n going from minus infinity
to infinity, we have to write
this as an integral as well.
And so that we can
reconstruct our function
y of t as an integral of
our Fourier coefficients
times the e to the i omega t.
See that?
It's essentially the same thing.
It's just that we're turning
this sum into an integral.
All right.
So that's called a
Fourier transform.
And that's the inverse Fourier
transform, this [INAUDIBLE]
from a function to
Fourier coefficients.
And this takes your
Fourier coefficients
and goes back to your function.
All right, good.
Let me just show you
a few simple examples.
So let's start with the
function y of t equals 1.
So it's just a constant.
What is the Fourier transform?
So let's plug this into here.
Does anyone know what
that integral looks
like of the integral from
minus infinity to infinity
of e the minus i omega t
dt integrating over time.
It's a delta function.
There's only one value of omega
for which that function is not
0.
Remember, so let's say omega
equals 1, 1-- you know,
1 hertz.
This is just a bunch
of sines and cosines.
So when you integrate over
sines and cosines, you get 0.
Integral over time
of cosine is just 0.
But if omega is 0, then
what is e to the i omega t?
e to the i 0 is 1.
And so we're integrating
over 1 times dt.
And that becomes infinity
at omega equals 0.
And that's a delta
function, it's
0 everywhere except 4 at 0.
So that becomes
a delta function.
This Fourier transform of a
constant is a delta function.
And that's a really--
it's a really good one to know.
The Fourier transform of a
constant is a delta function.
That's called a
Fourier transform pair.
You have a function
and another function.
One function is the
Fourier transform
of the other function
that's called
a Fourier transform pair.
So the Fourier
transform of a constant
is just a delta function at 0.
You can invert that.
If you integrate, let's just
plug that delta function
into here.
If you integrate delta function
times e to the i omega t,
you just get e to the
i 0t, which is just 1.
So we can take the
Fourier transform of 1,
get a delta function,
[INAUDIBLE] inverse Fourier
transform the delta
function, and get back 1.
How about this
function right here?
This function is e
to the i omega 1.
It's a sine wave and a
cosine wave, a complex sine
and cosine, at
frequency omega 1.
Anybody know what the
Fourier transform of that is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So it's basically--
you can think of this--
that's the right answer.
Rather than try to explain
it, I'll just show you.
So the Fourier transform of
this is just a peak at omega 1.
And we can inverse Fourier
transform that and recover
our original function.
So those last few slides are
more for the aficionados.
You don't have to know that.
We're going to
spend time looking
at the discrete versions
of these things.
How about this case?
This is a simple
case where you have
a function that the
Fourier transform
of which has a peak at omega
1 and a peak at minus omega 1.
The Fourier transform of the
inverse Fourier transform
of that is just cosine omega 1t.
So a function, a cosine
function with frequency omega 1,
has two peaks, one
at frequency omega 1
and another one at
frequency minus omega 1.
So that looks a
lot like the case
we just talked about where
we had this complex Fourier
series.
And we had a peak at n equals
2 and another peak at n
equals minus 2.
And that function that gave
us that complex Fourier
series was cosine 2 omega t.
So that's just
what we have here.
We have a peak in the
spectrum at omega 1,
peak at minus omega
1, and that is
the Fourier decomposition
of a function that
is cosine omega 1t.
So it's just like
what we saw before
for the case of the
complex Fourier series.
So that was Fourier transform.
And now let's talk about the
discrete Fourier transform
and the associated
algorithm for computing
that very quickly called the
Fast Fourier Transform, or FFT.
So you can see computing
these Fourier transforms,
if you were to actually try
to compute Fourier transforms
by taking a function,
multiplying it
by these complex exponentials
like writing down
the value of e to the i omega t
at a bunch of different omegas
and a bunch of different
t's and then integrating
that numerically, that would
take forever computationally.
But it turns out that there's--
so you have to
compute that integral
over time for every omega
that you're interested in.
It turns out really, really
fast algorithm that you
can use for the
case where you've
got functions that
are sampled in time
and you want to extract the
frequencies of that signal
at a discrete set
of frequencies.
I'm going to switch
from using omega, which
is very commonly
used when you're
talking about
Fourier transforms,
to just using f, the frequency.
So it's just f is just 2 pi.
So omega is 2 pi f.
So here I'm just rewriting
the Fourier transform
and the inverse
Fourier transform
with f rather than omega.
So we're going to
start using f's now
for the discrete
Fourier transform case.
And we're going to
consider the case where
we have signals that are sampled
at regular intervals delta t.
So here we have a
function of time y of t.
And we're going to sample that
signal at regular intervals
delta t.
So this is delta t right here.
That time interval there.
So the sampling rate, the
sampling frequency, is just 1
over delta t.
So the way this works in
the fast Fourier transform
algorithm is you just
take those samples
and you put them into a
vector in MATLAB, just
some one-dimensional array.
And we're going to imagine
that our samples are
acquired at different times.
And let's [INAUDIBLE] minus
time step 8, minus 7, minus 6.
Time step 0 is in the
middle up to time step 7.
And we're going to say
that N is an even number.
The fast Fourier
transform works much,
much faster when N
is an even number,
and it works even faster when
N is a multiple, a power of 2.
So in this case,
we have 16 samples.
It's 2 to the 4.
Should usually try to make
your samples be a power of 2.
The number of samples.
So there is our function of time
sampled at regular intervals t.
So you can see that the
t min, the minimum time,
in this vector of sample
points in our function
is minus N over 2 delta t.
And that [INAUDIBLE] time is N
over 2 minus 1 times delta t.
And that's what the
MATLAB code would
look like to generate
an array of time values.
Does that make sense?
The FFT algorithm returns
the Fourier components
of that function of time.
And it returns the
Fourier components
in a vector that has the
negative frequencies on one
side and the
positive frequencies
on the other side
and the constant term
here in the middle.
The minimum frequency is N
over 2 times delta F. Oh,
I should say it returns the
Fourier components in steps
of delta f where delta F is
the sampling rate divided
by the number of time
steps that you put into it.
Don't panic.
This is just reference.
I'm showing you how
you put the data in
and how you get the data out.
When you put data into
the Fourier transform
algorithm, the
FFT algorithm, you
put in data that's
sampled at times,
and you have to know
what those times are.
If you want to make
a plot of the data,
you need to make an
array of time values.
And they just go from
a t min to a t max.
And there's a little
piece of MATLAB code
that produces that
array of times for you.
What you get back from
the Fourier transform,
the FFT, an array of not
values of the function of time,
but rather an array of
Fourier coefficients.
Just like we stuck in into our--
when we did the
complex Fourier series,
we stuck in a function of time.
And we get out a list
of Fourier coefficients.
Same thing here.
We put in a function
of time, and we get out
Fourier coefficients.
And the Fourier coefficients
are complex numbers associated
with different frequencies.
So let's say the
middle coefficient
that you get will
be the coefficient
for the constant term.
This coefficient down here
will be the coefficient
for the minimum frequency,
and that coefficient
will be the coefficient for
the maximum frequency, the most
positive frequency.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Ah, OK.
So I was hoping to just kind
of skip over that for now.
But when you do a discrete
Fourier transform,
turns out that the coefficient
for the most negative frequency
is always exactly the same as
the coefficient for the most
positive frequency.
And so they're
just given in one--
they're both given in
one element of the array.
You could replicate
that up here,
but it would be pointless.
And the length of the array
would have to be n plus 1.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: OK.
Good.
That question always comes
up, and it's a great question.
What we're trying
to do is to come up
with a way of representing
arbitrary functions.
So we can represent
symmetric functions
by summing together
a bunch of cosines.
We can represent
antisymmetric functions
by summing together
a bunch of sines.
But if we want to represent
an arbitrary function,
we have to use both
cosines and sines.
So we have this trick,
though, where we can,
instead of using
sines and cosines,
using these two
separate functions,
we can use a single function
which is a complex exponential
to represent things that can be
represented by sums of cosines
as well as things that can be
represented as sums of signs.
It's an arbitrary function.
And the reason is because
the complex exponential has
both a cosine in it and a sine.
So we can represent a cosine
as a complex exponential
with a positive
frequency, meaning
that it's a complex
number that goes
around this direction
plus another function
where the complex number is
going around in this direction.
So positive frequencies
mean as time increases,
this complex number is
going around the unit
circle in this direction.
Negative frequencies
mean the complex number's
going around in this direction.
And you can see that in
order to represent a cosine,
I need to have--
so let's see if I can do this.
Here's my e to the-- here's
my plus frequency going
around this way.
Here's my minus frequency
going around this way.
And you can see
that I can represent
a cosine if I can make the
imaginary parts cancel.
So if I have one function
that's going around like this,
another function that's
going around like this.
If I add them, then the
imaginary part cancels.
The sine cancels.
This plus this is
cosine plus cosine.
i sine minus i sine.
So the sines can--
the sine cancels.
And what I'm left
with is a sine.
So represent a cosine as
a sum of a function that
has a positive frequency
and a negative frequency.
You can see that
the y component,
the imaginary component,
cancels and all
I'm left with is the cosine
that's going across like this.
So it's just a
mathematical trick.
Positive and
negative frequencies
are just a mathematical trick to
make either the symmetric part
of the function or antisymmetric
part of the function cancel.
So I can just use these positive
and negative frequencies
to represent any function.
If I only had
positive frequencies,
I wouldn't be able to
represent arbitrary functions.
So just one more
little thing that you
need to know about
the FFT algorithm.
So remember we talked about if
you have a function of time,
negative times are over here,
positive times are over here.
You can put-- you can
sample your function
at different times and put
those different samples
into an array.
Before you send this
array of time samples
to the FFT algorithm,
you just need
to swap the right
half of the array
with the left half of the
array using a function called
time shifted arrays.
Don't worry about it.
It's just the guts
of the FFT algorithm
wants to have the positive
times in the first half
and the negative times
in the second half.
So you just do this.
Then you run the FFT function
on this time shifted array.
And what it spits
back is an array
with the positive
frequencies in the first half
and the negative frequencies
in the second half.
And you can just swap those
back using the circshift again.
That is your spectrum.
Your spectral coefficients.
Your Fourier coefficients
of this function.
Just MATLAB guts.
Don't worry about it.
So here's a piece of code
that computes the Fourier
coefficients of a function.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is define the number of points
that we have in our array.
2048.
So it's a power of 2.
So the FFT algorithm runs fast.
We're figuring out-- we're
going to write down a delta t.
In this case, it's
one millisecond.
The sampling rate, the
sampling frequency is just 1
over delta t.
So 1 kilohertz.
The array of times at
which the function sampled
is just going from
minus n over 2
to plus n over 2
minus 1 times delta t.
I'm defining the
frequency of a sine wave.
And we're now getting the
values of that cosine function
at those different times.
Does that make sense?
We're taking that
function of time
and circularly shifting
it by half the array.
So that's the circularly
shifted, the swapped values
of our function y.
We stick that into
the FFT function.
It gives you back the
Fourier coefficients.
You just swap it again.
And that is the spectrum, the
Fourier transform [INAUDIBLE]
signal.
And now you can
write down a vector
of frequencies of each one of
those Fourier coefficients.
Each one of those segments
in that vector y--
remember, there are 2,000
of them now, 2,048 of them--
each one of those is
the Fourier coefficient
of the function we
put in at each one
of those different frequencies.
Does that make sense?
Now let's take a look
at a few examples
of what that looks like.
So here is a function y of t.
It's cosine 2 pi f 0 t
where f 0 is 20 hertz.
So it's just a cosine wave.
You run this code on it.
And what you get back is an
array of complex numbers.
It has a real and imaginary
part as a function of frequency.
And you get this
cosine function.
It has two peaks, as promised.
It has a peak at plus 20 hertz
and a peak at minus 20 hertz.
One of those peaks
gives you an e
to the i omega t that
goes this way at 20 hertz.
The other one gives you
an e of the i omega t
that goes this way at 20 hertz.
And when you add them
together, if I can do that,
it gives you a cosine.
It goes back and
forth at 20 hertz.
That one.
Here's a sine wave.
y equals sine 2 pi f
0 t again at 20 hertz.
You run that code on it.
It gives you this.
Notice that-- OK, sorry.
Let me just point
out one more thing.
In this case, the peaks
are in the real part of y.
For the sine function,
the real part is 0
and the peaks are in
the imaginary part.
There's a plus i at
minus 20 i over 2,
actually, at minus 20 hertz,
a minus i at plus 20 hertz.
And what that does is when you
multiply that coefficient times
e to the i omega t and that
coefficient times whichever
the opposite one is.
One going this way, the
other one going this way.
You can see that the
real part now cancels.
And what you're left with is the
sine part that doesn't cancel.
And that is this
function sine omega t.
Any questions about that?
That's kind of boring.
We're going to put more
interesting functions in here
soon.
But I just wanted you to
see what this algorithm does
on the things that we've
been talking about all along.
And it gives you
exactly what you expect.
Remember, we can write
down any arbitrary function
as a sum of sines and cosines.
Which means we can write
down any arbitrary function
as a sum of these little
peaks and these peaks
at different frequencies.
Does that make sense?
So all we have to do is
find these coefficients,
these peaks, what values
of these different peaks
to stick in to reconstruct
any arbitrary function.
And we're going to do a lot
of that in the next lecture.
We're going to look at what
different functions here look
like in the Fourier domain.
We're going to do that for some
segments like a square pulse,
for trains of
pulses, for Gaussian,
for all kinds of
different functions.
And then using the
convolution theorem,
you can actually just
predict in your own mind
what different combinations of
those functions will look like.
So I want to end by talking
about one other really
critical concept called
the power spectrum.
And it's basically
usually what you
do when you compute the
Fourier transform of a function
is to figure out what
the power spectrum is.
The simple answer
is that all you do
is you square this thing.
Take the magnitude squared.
But I'm going to build
up to that a little bit.
So it's called the
power spectrum.
But first we need to understand
what we mean by power.
So we're going to
think about this
in the context of a
simple electrical circuit.
Let's imagine that this
function that we're
computing the Fourier
transform of, imagine
this function is voltage.
That's where this
idea comes from.
Imagine that this
function is the voltage
that you've measured
somewhere in a circuit.
Let's say in this
circuit right here.
Or current, either way.
So when you have current
flowing through this circuit,
you can see that sinusoid--
that some oscillatory
current, some
cosine, that drives
current through this resistor.
And when current flows to a
resistor, it dissipates power.
And the power
dissipated in a resistor
is just the current
times the voltage drop
across that resistor.
That means that the power--
now, remember,
Ohm's law tells you
that current is just voltage
divided by resistance.
So this is v divided by r.
So the power is just v
squared divided by r.
So if the voltage is just a
sine wave at frequency omega,
then v is some coefficient,
some amplitude at that
frequency times cosine omega t.
We can write that voltage
using Euler's equation as 1/2 e
to the minus i omega t plus
1/2 e to the plus i omega t.
And let's calculate the power
associated with that voltage.
Well, we have to average over
one cycle of that oscillation.
So the average
power is just given
by the square magnitude of the
Fourier transform [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's just plug
this into here.
And what you see is that the
power at a given frequency
omega is just that coefficient
magnitude squared over
resistance times 1/2 e to
the minus i omega t magnitude
squared plus 1/2 e
to the plus i over i
omega t magnitude squared.
And that's just
equal to 1 over r.
That coefficient
magnitude squared over 2.
So you can see that
the power dissipated
by this sinusoidal
voltage is just
that magnitude squared over 2.
So we can calculate the power
dissipated in any resistor
simply by summing up the
[INAUDIBLE] magnitude
of those coefficients.
So let's look at that
in a little more detail.
So let's think for a moment
about the energy that
is dissipated by a signal.
So energy is just the
integral over time.
Power is per unit time.
Total energy is
just the integral
of the power over time.
So power is just equal
to v squared over r.
So I'm just going to
substitute that in there.
So the energy of
a signal is just 1
over r times the integral
of v squared over time.
Now, there's an
important theorem
in complex analysis
called Parseval's theorem
that says that the integral over
the square of the coefficients
in time is just
equal to the integral
of the square magnitude
coefficients in frequency.
So what that's
saying is that it's
just the same as the
total power in the signal
or the total energy in a signal
if you represent it in the time
domain is just the same as
the total energy in the signal
if you look at it in
the frequency domain.
And what that's saying is
that the sum of all the
squared temporal
components is just
this equal to the sum of all the
squared frequency components.
And what that means
is that you can
see that each of these frequency
components, each component
in frequency contributes
independently
to the power in the signal.
What that means is
that you can think--
so you can think
of the total energy
in the signal as just the
integral over all frequencies
of this quantity here that
we call the power spectrum.
And so we'll often
take a signal,
calculate the
Fourier components,
and plot the area of
the Fourier transform,
the square magnitude of
the Fourier transform.
And that's called
the power spectrum.
And I've already said the total
variance of the signal in time
is the same as the total
variance of the signal
in the frequency domain.
So mathy people talk about
the variant of a signal.
The more engineering people talk
about the power in the signal.
But they're really talking
about the same thing.
So let's take this example
that we just looked at
and look at the power spectrum.
So that's a cosine function.
It has these two peaks.
Let me just point out
one more important thing.
For real functions,
so in this class,
we're only going to be talking
about real functions of time.
For real functions, the square
magnitude of the Fourier
transform is symmetric.
So you can see here
if there is a peak
in the positive
frequencies, there's
an equivalent peak in
the negative frequencies.
So when we plot the power
spectrum of a signal,
we always just plot
the positive side.
And so here's what
that looks like.
Here is the power spectrum
of a cosine signal.
And it's just a single peak.
So in that case, it was
a cosine at 20 hertz.
You get a single
peak at 20 hertz.
What does it look like
for a sine function?
What is the power spectrum
of a sine function?
Remember, in that case,
it was the real part was 0
and the imaginary part
had a plus peak here
and a minus peak here.
What does the spectrum
of that look like?
Right.
The square magnitude
of i is just 1.
Magnitude squared
So the power spectrum
of a sine function
looks exactly like this.
Same as a cosine.
Makes a lot of sense.
Sine and cosine are
exactly the same function.
One's just shifted
by a quarter period.
So it has to have the
same power spectrum.
It has to have the same power.
Let's take a look at a
different function of time.
Here's a train of
delta functions.
So we just have a bunch
of peaks spaced regularly
at some period.
I think it was--
I forget the exact number here.
But it's around 10-ish hertz.
Fourier transform of a
train of delta functions
is another train
of delta functions.
Pretty cool.
The period in the time
domain is delta t.
The period in the Fourier
domain is 1 over delta t.
That's another really important
Fourier transform pair for you
to know.
So the first Fourier transform
pair that you need to know
is that a constant in the time
domain is a delta function
in the frequency domain.
A delta function
in the time domain
is a constant in the
frequency domain.
A train of delta functions
in the time domain
is a train of functions in
the frequency domain and vice
versa.
And there's a very
simple relation
between the period
in the time domain
and the period in
the frequency domain.
What does the power spectrum of
this train of delta functions
look like?
It's just the square
magnitude of this.
So it just looks like
a bunch of peaks.
So here's another function.
A square wave.
This is exactly the same
function that we started with.
If you look at the
Fourier transform
of the imaginary part of 0,
the real part has these peaks.
So the Fourier transform-- so
these are now the coefficients
that you would put in front
of your different cosines
at different frequencies to
represent the square wave.
But what it looks like is
positive peak for the lowest
frequency, negative peak for the
next harmonic, positive peak,
and gradually
decreasing amplitudes.
The power spectrum of this--
oh, and one more point is that
if you look at the Fourier
transform of a higher
frequency square wave,
you can see that those
peaks move apart.
So you can transform.
So higher frequencies in the
time domain, stuff happening
faster in the time
domain, is associated
with things moving out to higher
frequencies in the frequency
domain.
You can see that the same
function higher frequencies
has the same Fourier transform
but with the components spread
out to higher frequencies.
And the power spectrum
looks like this.
And notice that one
more final point here
is that when you look at
power spectra, often signals
can have frequency
components that
are very small so that it's hard
to see them on a linear scale.
And so we actually plot
them in this method.
You plot them in
units of decibels.
And I'll explain what
those are the next time.
But that's another
representation of the power
spectrum of a signal.
OK, so that's what
we've covered.
And we're going to continue
with the game plan next time.